Tim Burton monkey symbolism opening eyes
are really scary cliche 3 minutes and 15
seconds of King opening credits obvious
simulator is obvious unexpected Mark
Wahlberg hello again Mark Wahlberg is
addicted monkeys Jesus ship reading
facility dedicated to animal research
needs to warn its crew about live
animals probably because it figures into
the plot later monkeys are in cages and
that makes me feel bad cliche Mark
Wahlberg is yet again a dick to monkeys
when you frustrate them they lose focus
caging them makes them feel warm and
cozy movie rips off the video postcard
from every sci-fi movie ever also
there's no way this many people love
this guy why would he keep his apartment
down on earth when he's on an indefinite
mission in space this is an orgy of
evidence that the prop guy would
dispense her gifts this guy is such a
badass he doesn't have to zip up his
uniform cliche I'm getting every
electronic communication from Earth from
all time how could you possibly know
this
also Hitler Iwo Jima Bill Clinton an
Asian chef equal everything also earth
is broadcasting only iconic moments also
Hitler and that's racist why don't you
just allow me to do my job why don't you
allow me to do my job cliche he's the
canary
that's the coal mine that's racist I
know this needs to be a monkey because
it's a movie called Planet of the Apes
but why do they even need a monkey they
have all this futuristic but they can't
send some sort of remote control pod
they control from the ship sure this
ship can pick up frequency patterns but
it can't pick up that a pod is being
used 20 feet away sir
Delta pod is launched ship can detect
pod only when it launches and not any
other thing it might do those are some
useless sensors this pond somehow knows
exactly what year it is also british
calendar the proximity of these
celestial bodies signify the coming of
an apocalypse that should happen Oh
every day captain Davidson survives this
crash and that simple is it we interrupt
this Mark Wahlberg Tim Burton monkey
movie to bring you the Dagobah crash
from the prior Strikes Back fire from
the ship at the bottom of the lake
magically leaps to the surface out of
all the places captain Davidson could
crash land on this mostly desolate
planet he finds the one area at the
exact time when fellow humans and
potential friends are running away from
cheap antagonists these monkeys have
gotten really good at throwing kids into
burlap sacks in the middle of the woods
things
excitement horses physics it doesn't
appear that Davidson has been punched in
the nose so hard that he would've been
thrown 20 feet
rounding up humans is simply a business
venture
why did I need an entire army to get
this job done jungle trampoline also how
did this monkey know from the jungle to
jump exactly this far what he can't
possibly see his target monkeys don't
say anything until it's time for it to
be dramatic Tim Roth is an anti circus
in this scene also is bad that I know
this is Tim Roth behind all that monkey
makeup haha
Planet of the Apes reference also
Davidsons known as made out of
adamantium hookah is an evolutionary
inevitability
why does everyone need to see you're
getting groomed also spinning barber
pole irony basketball is an evolutionary
inevitability
he's a skankiest scavengers humans I've
ever seen
Paul Giamatti turned in this clip as his
audition for 12 years of slave these are
the only two assholes who need the neck
harness everyone else all good why do
they bother separating women from men
when they end up in the same place
earlier we saw a Limbaugh buying these
humans and it sounded like they had a
choice on whether or not he buys them so
if he didn't buy them where would all
these humans go would they not be in the
same prison anyway also if the military
is rounding up humans why did they sell
these humans limbo and then buy any of
them back if they need a human why don't
they just take what they need before
selling them also limbo keep your eye on
this one feisty
captain Davidson has not done anything
feisty also the only one who was shown
feistiness is apparently not worthy of
watching out for because he's not Mark
Wahlberg joint saying you don't want
your house is a human teenager this
movie is full of this bold unexplained
anger is unexplained that's a surprise
they're not dumb making me talk okay
this movie needs to pick an issue either
this is wrong because they view the
humans as monkeys or it's wrong because
they view them sleeves but it can't be
both at once because if a monkey could
talk like these humans do I'm pretty
sure we wouldn't bother putting them in
cages and experimenting on them that's
what this one seems different you can't
tell one from the other this movie is
full of this bull I'm wash your hands
before dinner
monkeys suddenly are British everyone
who is important to this story has been
invited that the Senators dinner Reserve
Bank's the using those heavy-handed
religious and political overtones monkey
dentist also for someone who hates
monkeys for smelling like humans he sure
likes touching humans in an intimate way
also the only way he could have made
this dinner more heavy-handed his Burton
directed it like it was the Last Supper
floss
pointless protests easiest lock to pick
ever there's a curfew for humans there's
a curfew for slaves you had to come
right all right you did exactly the
right thing and now I'm gonna kill you
cliche number don't start now
Roth dude off duty ape decides that
smelling humans is not worth his time
right now scene does not contain the
lapdance
stealthy escape includes running through
the Senators 6/10 handy chandelier for
hilarious fraidy-cat moment monkey
hairpiece and dentures beautiful you
show me how we had here I promise you
I'll show you something little change a
little forever his penis this guy must
have been standing here right by this
door just in case someone knocked
why didn't you just throw it at that
asshole we really needed magically
appearing paid to do this job what do
you know what my fault cat fight pigs
are afraid of the water
apes have the same weakness as the
aliens from science how many times are
we gonna hear some bull about what
humans can do and what Apes can do in
this movie that's half the movie if they
cut out 90% of this we would get to the
point this movie could be an hour long
although it still works after being
submerged in water for many hours trully
create high power Ella actually this is
the 800-pound pilot all the adults allow
Billy Elliot to do the fighting for them
and you only know yourself to his level
you only lower yourself to his level
cliche can't we all just get along like
me declare martial law this senator can
just declare martial law what happened
to them God after we cut down a forest
sure just put in a dumb environmental
message in your talking ape movie in the
time before time we were the slaves and
the humans were the last
ape somehow kept this secret for
thousands of years buddha monkey so they
kept this gun in a piece of pottery for
thousands of years
also guns are bad charlton heston didn't
want to be credited on this movie also
NRA spokesperson speaks up the evil of
guns in this movie also convenient
deathbed exposition is convenient ensure
these ascared of water you just saw re
scream when she saw water also why are
you asking Billy Elliot this question
bad guys get distracted with infighting
so the good guys can sneak up on
Davidson shoots this at eye level when
the flare shoots way up into the sky why
go through the exact middle of this camp
also why would you shoot a flare and not
make sure they're gonna go investigate
it first before charging 20 seconds of
panting bar horses at are ran all the
way back to tell they'd this why
couldn't just get an underling to do
this
jumping tantrum I'd like to see a wild
progerin poke in toy in a cage - yeah
until she opened her mouth movie steals
the video thing from Star Trek the
motion picture this thing still thing
working also this asshole ship is still
sending out a beacon even if we accept
that the ship took a lot of damage and
it's been sitting here forever
how are the electrical connections not
severed names we brought a log have been
very helpful they were a lot stronger
and a lot smarter we ever imagined so
the Apes evolved in like 30 years but I
did find time to calmly leave this
message while the world burned around me
the story is spreading through the
villages how is his story spreading he's
been here for two days the only people
who know him are right here and there's
no messaging system also even if his
story is spreading how do they know to
come here all at once this is a little
close to just now be seeing this huge
army right also shouldn't the 8 bar me
be seeing Billy Elliot right now slavery
bran just happens to be in this tent
ready to go for any branding at a
moment's notice there's no reason to let
her go and not just kill her now it's
bad enough that the kid had to disobey
and join this but now he loses control
of the horse at this crucial moment
horse gets back on his feet with the use
of a sound effect see no Simos
tremendous explosion only stuns the Apes
ah
Wilhelm clan managed to make it on the
Oberon thousands of years ago to keep
the tradition alive old friends who
turned into enemies find each other on
the battlefield cliche real adversaries
drop all their weapons before final
fight what are you waiting for
also I'm gonna shoot your face will
leave the graves unmarked no one who
comes here will be able to tell Apes
from humans races society turns it
around in ten seconds about I hit my
pill came from the stars changed our
world overnight
who ate Lincoln maybe the second movie
will explain how general Thade got here
before davidson and changed the earth
forever before he got back
you get your monkey ready she's me sir
this is a waste of time clever girl
all the coy
I live in ago
until our enemies that they may take our
lives but they'll never take oh right on
get a chat take it big we do let you
leave you back to the place where the
caught off I gotta go home and get my
hat forget you we have what are you
kidding me
big doctor one of what gooble gobble
gobble
Oh me
Oh